though it's technically continuation of
the blackops sub-series call of duty
black ops 4 kind of exists in its own
realm both multiplayer and zombies mix
old and new content in the new battle
royale mode blackout is an entirely new
direction for the series I recently
played black ops for a pre-launch event
covering the standard multiplayer
zombies and blackout I still want more
time with each mode as well as the
specialist training missions before I
give a final verdict so stay tuned for
the full review early next week
multiplayer is the most straightforward
of the modes and black ops 4 takes a
more tactical approach than previous
entries the wall running and thrust
jumping of black ops 3 is gone replaced
with a way grounded feel that forces you
to be a bit more thoughtful about
positioning healing is now manual to and
on a cooldown timer
matches overall have a slightly slower
more cautious pace but time to kill us
still low and frequent firefights keep
things exciting the mattes generally
stick to the familiar three lane
structure and are longer and narrower
than those in black ops 3 providing
opportunities for both close quarters
and long range encounters black ops
three specialists return with some
tweaks each still has a unique weapon
and ability but instead of choosing one
or the other you now go into a match
with both the weapon is tied to a longer
cooldown and functions like a super
while the ability is a piece of
equipment like a grenade or a trap with
a more strategic purpose some
specialists are more obviously geared
towards certain roles that is if they're
good for offense defense or support but
most modes don't give you much of a
reason to follow those guidelines if you
don't want to this isn't a hero shooter
and your success is more dependent on
effectively using your regular loadout
than your skill with a particular
specialist or your team's composition as
a result though the more tactical
aspects feel robbed of their impact and
committing to them isn't any more
rewarding than a normal kill
Zombies is as broad as it is deep with
two separate storylines across three
maps for if you have the blackops pass
included in the game special editions
the first two nine and voyage of despair
are part of the brand-new chaos story
the third blood of the Dead may be
joined by classified to make up the
returning either story it's a lot to
take in at once and I still need to
really dive into each map I'm most
intrigued by voyage of despair though
partially because of its Titanic setting
but also because it's tight spaces pose
a greater challenge than nines more open
arenas over in the either storyline the
Ultima screw has an age particularly
well even considering that each of them
is stereotyped to the extreme the jokes
just don't land anymore especially
Tokyo's overdone Japanese accent where
ELLs are replaced with ours at every
opportunity
suffering that you crave our you will
not be us aside from that slowly
uncovering the omage maps secrets is a
tantalizing prospect the new rush mode
is a much faster paced version of
zombies where you don't have to do any
thinking or puzzle solving you're just
there to kill the undead horde style
there's no money so you don't need to
save up to unlock a door either you're
instead told which area will have the
next rush wave and you're directed from
room to room as you go it's too intense
to be a tutorial per se but it's a great
way to familiarize yourself with the map
test weapons and maybe figure out which
rooms you should aim to reach first in
classic mode
since it's the brand-new load blackout
is obviously the most intriguing aspect
of black ops 4 but because there was a
limited number of people at the
pre-launch event I didn't get to play
many rounds or experience matchmaking on
live populated servers I want to spend
more time with the mode but as it's very
similar to pub G I also generally know
what to expect from blackout it
undoubtedly captures the intense shaky
excitement that makes battle royale so
popular with Call of Duty's tight
shooting and movement mechanics as a
strong foundation areas with zombies at
a PvE element that helps distinguish
blackout from the likes of pub g2
offering powerful loot at the risk of
dying from an undead mob or attracting
human players to your position perks and
specialist equipment also worked their
way into blackout as items that can be
looted during a match providing another
small but distinct Call of Duty twist
sure there isn't a traditional
single-player campaign but call of duty
black ops 4 isn't short on content and
its three main modes are substantial
with standard multiplayer in zombies it
struggles to fully commit to moving
forward and the mix of old content and
new ideas doesn't always gel from what
I've played so far black out more
successfully incorporates elements of
black ops past while forming its own
take on trends at the present but
because each mode is deep in its own
right I'll be spending more time with
black ops 4 post-launch before posting
my final review you might want to hold
him down
[Music]